salah abdeslam sat expressionless as the
judge delivered the verdicts the only
surviving suspected attacker was found
guilty of terrorism and murder and
sentenced to life in prison without
parole during the trial the belgian-born
frenchman said that he had decided not
to blow himself up
but the judge said the court considered
that the explosive vest had
malfunctioned abduslam's childhood
friend mohamed abrini who drove him from
paris to brussels on the night of the
attacks was also given a life sentence
he was also found guilty of terrorism as
were 18 other men one other was found
guilty of fraud
the sentences are not excessive they
reflect the events and those behind them
i think it's a satisfying moment for
everyone and for the justice system
it was nearly seven years ago that 10
attackers rampaged across paris killing
people in cafes the bataclan concert
hall and outside france's national
sports stadium by the end of the night
130 people were dead hundreds injured
isil claimed responsibility across
france there was shock and grief
the trial into the paris attacks was the
biggest in french history it lasted
nearly 10 months hundreds of witnesses
testified and while some victims chose
to stay away others came to the court
nearly every day
muhammad amgar was injured when an
attacker blew himself up outside the
stadium he says he found it helpful to
attend the trial most days now it's over
he hopes that he can move forward i will
close the book and i will go on my life
i will try to to keep going
this this story this this this thing
happened in my life it was part of my
life so i have to live with i have no
choice so i have to live with i accepted
before it was very hard for me to accept
it but i have to accept it now it's
about me
abdeslam will serve his sentence in
france or belgium where he's already in
prison for the victims survivors and
their relatives the verdicts won't
change the past bring back loved ones or
heal their suffering but for some there
will at least be a sense that finally
justice has been served natasha butler
al jazeera paris